ROBERT CROWE: Hi and welcome
to Coding TensorFlow.
I'm Robert Crowe, and today
we'll be learning how to get
started using TensorFlow
to create and train
a model when the result we need
is a single number, like maybe
a price or a probability, or
in this case, miles per gallon.
In other words, a
regression problem.
Real quick.
Let's talk for a moment
about a regression
problem versus a
classification problem.
Regression and
classification are probably
the two most commonly
solved problems
with machine learning today.
Today, we're going to be
working on a regression problem.
So we want our model to look
at an example from our data
and predict a number.
Usually that will be a
floating point number.
Now, if we were doing a
classification problem,
then we'd want our model to
look at an example from our data
and tell us which class or
group it thinks this example is.
So it might be
telling us that it
thinks this example is a fish
or a bird or maybe a weasel.
But today, we're
doing regression.
Specifically, today, we're going
to look at training a model
to tell us the miles per
gallon of cars from the 1970s
by looking at data,
like their weight,
the number of cylinders,
the horsepower.
Just look at these beauties.
Miles per gallon
is a single number.
So regression is the
right thing here.
OK.
One more thing.
We're going to be using Keras.
If you haven't heard
of Keras before,
it's a high level API
for deep learning,
and it's very user friendly.
And it's really powerful too.
And today, we're just going
to scratch the surface.
OK, let's get started.
So today, we're going
to be using seaborn.
And seaborn isn't installed
by default on a co-lab.
So we're going to pull
it with a PIP install.
You can totally do
that in a co-lab.
You can install
whatever you need to.
OK.
That's it.
Seaborn's installed.
That was quick.
Now we're going to go
through the other imports
that we need to do.
Pandas, and of course,
TensorFlow itself,
including Keras.
OK, that's good.
So now we've got version
1.13 of TensorFlow.
TensorFlow includes a
lot of great data sets.
But today, we're going
to be reaching out
to a data set that's at the
University of California
at Irvine.
It's a great resource.
They have this repository
of public domain data sets.
And it's a great tool when
you're looking for data.
Keras makes it really easy for
us to download our data set.
You can see the URL right
there of the UCI repository.
Then, because it's easier
to see what we're doing,
we're going to give
our columns some names.
And then we want to
take a look at our data
and just see what it looks like.
That's always a
good thing to do.
And pandas will help us do that.
Data's almost never clean.
Even data that you've gotten
for something like UCI.
So we need to make sure that
all our data is good values.
One of the things we're going
to look for is unknown values.
And you can see from this
that there are six of them
in the Horsepower column.
In this case, there's
only six rows.
So we can be safe
just dropping them.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So we have one column
that's different.
The Origin column.
It's not a numeric column.
It's categorical.
And usually with a
categorical column,
you want to convert it to what's
known as a one hot column.
So to do that, we're going to
first remove the Origin column.
And then we're going to
create three new columns, one
for each country that the
cars could be coming from.
And each of those will
only have a value of 1
when the car came
from that country.
Let's take a look at that.
So we're going to split
our data in two pieces.
80% of it, or you can see
there, a fraction of 0.8,
we're going to keep in
our training data set.
And the other is going
to be our test data set.
So you might be wondering,
why did we split our data?
Well, we want it
to do well on data
that it's never seen before.
So what we're going to do
is split it into two pieces
and keep one of those pieces.
And we're only going
to use that when
we're ready to test
our model and see
how well it does for data
it's never seen before.
That's called generalization.
A model that does well on data
that it's never seen before
generalizes well.
So now let's take
another look at our data.
Specifically, let's
look at the miles
per gallon, the cylinders, the
displacement, and the weight.
To do that, we're going
to use seaborn's pair plot
utility, which gives us a nice
plot of the joint distributions
of each of our features along
with kernel density estimation
plots, or KDE plots,
along the diagonal.
If you haven't seen
them before, KDE plots
are essentially just
smooth histograms.
So you can see there are
some clear relationships
between some of our features.
OK.
Now let's look at some summary
statistics of our features
like the mean, the standard
deviation, the minimum,
the quartiles, and the maximum.
One of the things I
want you to notice here
is that the ranges of these
values are very different.
And that's not a
good thing in general
when you're training a
machine learning model.
So we're going to be fixing
that in a little bit.
The next thing we need
to do is make sure
that we're not giving our
model the right answer,
meaning we don't want to give
it the labels in our training
data.
Or for that matter,
in our test data.
So we need to split those
off from our data sets.
OK, so it's time to deal
with those ranges of values
that were really different.
We need to do something called
normalization of our features.
When we do that,
all of our features
will fall between 0 and 1.
And the way we accomplish
that is essentially
by using a z-score.
We subtract the
mean and then divide
by the standard deviation.
So let's do that now.
So now we're ready
to build our model.
And Keras makes it really easy.
We're going to use Keras
sequential, which gives us
a fully connected model.
It's going to have three layers.
All three are dense layers.
The first to have
a relu activation.
And the first one
needs to know what
the shape of the input data is.
The last layer doesn't
have an activation, meaning
that it's a linear activation.
And for a regression
model, that's what we want.
OK.
We also need to give
it an optimizer.
We're going to use
RMSprop for that.
And we need a loss function.
We're going to use mean
squared error for that.
And we need to give it metrics.
The metrics are what
we're going to use to see
how well our model is doing.
We'll give it mean squared
error and mean absolute error.
OK.
Let's go ahead and
create our model.
You can ignore those warnings.
Those things come up sometimes.
Now let's take a look at
a summary of our model.
Keras makes it really
easy to do that.
So you can see that we
have our three layers.
And notice that we have 4,865
trainable parameters, even
for a very simple
model like this.
That's a lot to try to train.
But Keras and TensorFlow
make that easy.
Now we can go ahead and try our
model, even though we haven't
trained it, and just make
sure that it produces
results and doesn't blow up.
Let's go ahead and do that now.
So there.
Now we've got some
results from our model,
and we haven't trained it,
so of course, those numbers
are meaningless.
But the shape is right and
it didn't throw any errors.
So things are looking good.
So now we're ready
to train our model.
We're going to train
it for 1,000 epochs.
Each epoch is a pass through
all of our training data.
And as we do that, we
want to print a dot
so that we know that our
model is still training.
Sometimes this could take days.
We want to make sure
it's still training.
So to do that, we're going
to create a print dot class.
The other thing we're going to
do is split off 20% of our data
in a validation set.
And we'll use that to test
our model as we're training
it to see how it's doing.
OK.
Let's go ahead and
train our model.
See those dots?
We want something
like those dots.
If this was taking
a week, we'd want
to make sure that we knew
that it was still going.
And there we go.
It's done.
So we saved a history
object and we can
look at our training results.
Let's do that now.
There we go.
You see we've got loss,
our mean absolute error
and mean squared error.
Those were our metrics.
And we've got the same
things for validation.
Validation loss, validation
mean absolute error.
But wait a minute.
Something looks wrong
with those numbers.
The loss and the validation
loss are going up.
Let's take another look at this.
A lot of times,
plotting will really
help to see what's going on.
We're going to use
matplotlib to do that.
And we're going to
plot learning curves,
one for each of our metrics.
So there are our curves.
The green is our
validation error.
And you'll notice,
wait a minute.
The green is going up.
That's not good.
This is classic overfitting.
So how do you fix it?
Well, there's lots
of different ways.
But today we're going
to use something
called early stopping.
Early stopping is
really very simple.
It just stops trading
the model as soon
as the model stops improving.
One of the things
you need to specify
is what should it look for?
In this case, we're going
to look at validation loss.
And how patient should it be?
How long should it wait
before it decides that things
aren't getting better?
So let's go ahead and
train our model again.
But this time, we
use early stopping.
And look at that.
Those curves are perfect.
Both the validation loss
and the training loss
are going down together.
Let's look at how well our
model is doing overall.
We'll look at the
mean absolute error.
Look at that.
It's 1.8 miles per gallon off.
Is that good?
Well, you decide.
But for me, if I was trying to
predict the miles per gallon
of a car by looking at the
cylinders and the weight,
I don't think I could
do any better than that.
So now we're ready to
make some predictions.
We'll make several and
then plot them out.
Look at that.
That's really not too bad.
If they were perfect,
they'd all be on that line.
But they're all pretty close,
so really, not too bad.
Let's check and see what
our error looks like.
We'll use a histogram for that.
So it's pretty close to a
Gaussian, but not quite.
With a data set this
small, you wouldn't
expect it to be perfect.
So that was great.
We learned a lot today.
We learned about mean
squared error loss.
We learned about metrics
that help us understand
how well our model is training.
We learned about
normalization, which
helps us prepare our data.
And we learned about
early stopping, which
helps us deal with overfitting.
Thanks for watching.
Tune in next time.
If you have any questions or
comments, post them below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the TensorFlow channel
for more stuff like this.